CARTER MORGAN: Creating
a safe work environment
is more important than ever.
Not only can it
help protect workers
from injury and illness,
but it can raise morale,
reduce absenteeism and
turnover, and improve
overall productivity.
However, creating a
working environment
where employees both
are safe and feel safe
can be challenging.
For instance, proper safety
protocols and procedures
have to be clear, accessible,
and easy for everyone
to follow.
Appropriate feedback
channels must be in place
so safety concerns can
be reported and addressed
in a short amount of time.
Safety documentation
and procedures
have to be meticulously
tracked, stored, and protected.
This can be a huge undertaking,
but luckily, Google Cloud
is here to help.
By leveraging Google
Cloud technology,
organizations can
create a workplace
that is more productive,
safer, and happier.
Let's see how an
organization could
use these products to
better identify and address
their safety issues.
Meet Ashley.
Ashley leads the safety team
at a growing manufacturing
company.
Although they don't have
any coding experience,
Ashley and her team
have created a suite
of safety apps using AppSheet,
Google Cloud's no-code app
development platform.
Each of their employees
and contractors
are able to download
these apps and access them
at any time on their
mobile devices.
One day Han, who works in
the manufacturing facility,
slips and almost falls
while walking up the stairs
outside their building.
Instead of ignoring
the incident,
Han knows that
there is an easy way
to report any risk he notices.
He's able to open up his
safety risk reporting app
and fill out a form
detailing the safety risk,
including the risk
level, details, picture,
and even annotations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Once he completes
the form, Ashley,
who is on the safety
board, is immediately
notified of the issue.
She's able to open the report,
read through the details,
and claim the ticket.
Ashley wants to understand
the situation better,
so she sets up a
meeting to talk to Han.
They join a Google
Meet video call
so they can talk face to face.
Her team decides they would
like to hire a contractor
to install railings along
both sides of the stairs.
They work with the
management, legal,
and finance teams in real
time to update and finalize
the contract.
Back in the app, Ashley is able
to document the steps taken
to address this risk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Once the contractor is finished
installing the railings,
Ashley is able to close the
ticket by selecting Resolve.
This is just one example of
the many types of safety apps
you could build.
Using these Google
Cloud solutions,
creating applications
such as these
can take days or weeks,
not months or years
to build, allowing businesses to
work safer, faster, and better.
To learn more and to access
this and other app templates,
click on the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]